Charlie Murphy told us a story of you
and him coming over your house in a
limousine and you Ella it was a lion or
a tiger tiger theme of throw the line
for the tiger
dude what made you think you could get a
tiger so I'm in prison at the time so
I'm in prison I'm talking to my car
dealer at the time and he had some cars
to belong to a friend of mine and he's
discussing if he doesn't pay for these
cars I'm a Sully's cars to someone and
get some horses if I said what you need
a horse Cougars lions tigers so you do
can you get me some Tigers yeah and I
got a man's not cool that baby being
after Martin or Ferrari have a tiger
right next to you that would be cool
right yeah give me some Cubs man then I
came home I had those Cubs right there
waiting for me now never gets this is a
crazy picture you and your underwear
with a tiger on chain that is that is
one of the that's right there that's you
a peak crazy
yeah and thing yeah going through my
mind know what made me think about my
friends that might you can get some
awesome animals I'm gonna get for
everybody does it though those are one
of the things about what's his face from
narcos Oh Pablo esta aqui got like a
[ __ ] zoo they all do it don't you get
like that rich you're like just get some
animal people with the line yeah
[Music]